[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans coming at you
from scenic Torrance California where
I'm joined by Chef Andy Matsuda chef
Andy is the CEO and mastermind behind
sushi chef Institute an intensive two
month long course that churns out some
of the best American sushi chefs in the
game chef andis gonna see if I have what
it takes to make it his classroom
hopefully I make the grade and that
actually leads me to my first question
because you know you always hear about
sushi masters spending tens of thousands
of hours perfecting their craft is it
possible to get on top of these
techniques in a couple of months or in
my case like two hours we try we try the
best we can we do here teaching onion
five things we need a sharpie and I
second one cutting up fish throw the one
we do make me a sushi rice and for
someone you get eat and buy full only
five things very short condense it well
no one needs more teaching than me chef
Andy let's get right to it we have a
fish in front of us what step one so we
need to have a scale off then that we
can do a fillet what kind of fish are
were using right now
this one is called straight back from
raisin and Baja California leave no
scales on this fish yeah no scale can't
eat it be gentle we can't break into
meat yeah I'm going kind of hard be
gentle
you never really realize how many scales
are on a fish you just start taking them
off
fish nice and smooth totally dis scale
what's step number two now we need to do
head off off with its head - yeah then
if elating okay that's cool are we
holding a sight grab this side fin fin
here bottom fin not a straight a little
bit angle and told it to the middle bone
lifting the fin up cutting beneath the
fin beach scimitar bone reaching the
middle bone yeah don't cut the bone
don't cut the bone I'm reaching the
middle bone and then just chilling right
here now holding the head holding uh
tails and then breaking the neck and
then pull out so we don't need to cut
the bone in again alright P now we got
to fillet this fish so tail - you tail
to me
we cut in a 45 angle this is the frak
this is an ID so 45 angle just sits cut
the skin lonely alright little tip of
the knife just getting through the skin
only going all the way to the top here
so even though we're chopping heads off
and filleting up it's still a finesse
game so just say that should be off
already
hmm let's see if mine did that I'm not
sure yeah okay so now we can do little
by little
whoa actually wait maybe I did do that
right look at me fillet a fish good chef
[Music]
so we've filleted our straight bass
we're gonna wrap it up keep it dry keep
it under 40 degrees keep it fresh
because we have some more work to do
before we get back to the bass this to
me looks like a big piece of tuna hey
what do we have here and what are we
gonna do to this thing this one is a
yellowfin tuna but we need to do just
one that can do sashimi so we need to
break it down or Kosaku doggy style
obviously there's a lot of fish here how
do we get it down to its sushi size we
can show you to how we do
Jimmy and to the right sign and sushi
coming to the left side how big are you
cutting these pieces each one I have
about 15 gram that meaning 1/2 ounces
per a piece is a nice bite size and then
sushi size we need to do you can see the
grain in here right so we can serve it
to the grain baguette it's too chewy
so we need to do against the grain it's
like a dance
very graceful I can see how you fall in
love with this I can see that I feel
like I'm getting the hang of it and then
I look at like my slices and all of
yours look more or less the same and I
see that mine is a much more of a
snowflake situation it's just sort of
all over the place but that's my
signature style okay you know what I'm
take a look world Sean Evans cutting
some sushi
[Music]
the rice is out and the big
misconception about sushi is everybody
thinks that it's about the fish but I
know that sometimes I have a sushi
apprentices spent years on just the rice
can you talk to me about how important
the Rice's and what goes into making the
perfect rice sushi rice should we use
them for short grain or a medium show
grain and we need to do cooking by about
45 minutes cooking by a nice cooker and
after that we have vinegar solution
vinegar sugar salt combination pool
mixing and it takes about a process to
the two hours but one thing is when
you're studying a dry hand and touch the
rice or stick to you it's sticky
two fingers only and drop in and I
moisture your hand and a fresh is the
extra moisture sow right this out and
then we're making the giri right and for
those who don't know that's the rice and
this yeah New Guinea started to probably
by 250 years ago it's a fish and rice
put together you
should be big but now in a small portion
of it the fish is coming to the left
hand
rice is coming to the small one but I am
to the 15 grams little little ball yeah
and wasabi right in the middle of fish
little finger action uh-huh
and the rice is about up into the 15
gram and then we need to do a free fall
over and upside down and we need to do
grabbing a two finger and a side to side
side to side up on a finger on and here
and two finger a touch a rotate and I
pinch it again and two finger what kind
of shape will be turning this into
because I notice you have a very
graceful it's alright round it out like
a 1950's Mustang mine is just sort of
stacked all right tuna check now I guess
we'll just bust that bass out of the
fridge do one more roll and then I'll
present my midterm okay you okay so we
need to do filet sashimi style then we
need to do Rob paint and a California
roll and then we do torching grab the
seaweed rice by tennis ball-sized one
two three four five and six putting some
crab down cucumber some cucumber down
avocado putting some avocado in a thing
so deliberate so graceful there's an art
to it how tight should this be packed we
need we need a cut so we need a pretty
tight
[Music]
feels a little advanced for my first day
but here goes nothing
just like watering the grass
[Music]
all right so here we have the finished
product if you're at home and you can't
tell which is which I could understand
here's chef's here's mine chef's if
maybe you could go through what I've
made today tell me what I did well and
then tell me where I fell a little bit
short so needy is we're gonna want to
ten we can get to four okay we need a
training special role and Sierra bass a
role eight that's good that's good right
that's melody I'll take they're gonna
take that now California roll we did a
first time role probably about halfway
five five and you know what I think you
know why because some of these are ones
okay this one's a one yeah I'm not gonna
shy away from that it's a one I know it
I'll own it but then this is a ten
that's how I think we end up at five you
know like some of them are tens some of
them are ones and then we end up BAM
right now you know what your chef goes
through when they make your sushi roll
so I want to say thank you for your time
I very much appreciate it shout out to
the sushi chef Institute and if you want
to give it a shot at home I say go for
it you know it's like stand-up comedy
it's gonna stink your first hundred
times that's why you gotta go onstage
101 times until you get it
same with sushi just keep making it just
keep cranking those rolls and eventually
hopefully you'll end up with something
that you can actually right
[Music]